overstated a coast-to-coast roast of the
50 states he's also got an hbo max
uh and hbo max special to talk about
he is none other than colin quinn how
you been sir
hey what's going on how's it going
what's going on in the world
good everything good you're hanging in
there tip top shape not good but yeah
i know we were talking earlier about uh
mtv and just remembering you from that
how old were you when you popped on mtv
on remote control 28 28 i was
i was a very old 28. i was a one down
28.
a worn down 28. did you know what you
were involved with on that show remote
control when you were doing it did you
sense it did you know that you're a part
of something
huge pop culture colin yeah well
at first we did it and we me and ken was
the other guy
we were like comedians so we were like
oh my god this show you know what is
this nonsense
and then we started doing it we're like
you know it is fun they let us do
whatever we wanted
the guys the producers which was mike
duke and joe devo
like they were so fun like we were part
of like this whole
crowd of people that hung out together
it was not there was not a lot of uh
you know we just all hung out and and
they just let you do whatever you wanted
because
they didn't they didn't care they're
like yeah do whatever you want on the
show
and then we didn't know how popular it
was so we went to spring break that year
so we shot it in december it was on for
january february
new york it's cold and we don't really
know and then we go down to spring break
and thousands of kids start chanting
every little line from the show and just
even the commercials they would imitate
me doing they come up
and we were like wow this is big yeah
yeah
and you kind of looked at each other and
go where this is you had no idea yeah
yeah we had no idea it was that big ah
and um do you still stay in touch with
ken or no you're a long guy no he passed
away about that
i forgot about that yeah i'm so sorry
funny guy but i kept to talk to them
till then yeah oh no kidding
so is that how so basically you were is
that how you were discovered colin is
that how you would say was that that's
how that happened
that was definitely that was definitely
the first thing yeah okay
um and then um eventually as we all know
snl knocked on your door we're talking
about how you got the gig
of uh of uh the news reader if you will
the uh
oh yeah that was update so you got the
gig when uh when norm got the gate right
yeah yeah that was uh
that was awkward but you went on and you
did your job you crushed it
um so yeah yeah go for it
sorry you were about to say oh no go
ahead so what were you gonna say no i
was gonna say what was your favorite i
guess moment from when you were on the
the weekend update
colin um i mean bill murray came on once
and he just did you know he did like he
just kind of free formed his thing you
know
and i go because i'm from that
generation where i was like
i'm sitting next to bill murray and he's
being like
you know irreverent bill murray and i
was that was kind of like a real
moment for me where i was like you know
and then um you know obviously bill
murray uh uh
being part of uh the history of saturday
night live had something to do with that
too
um tell me about your this book
overstated a coast-to-coast roast of the
50 states
available now where all books are sold
how did you concoct the idea and
what what people should know about it
colin well i mean obviously i'm going
over each state and kind of you know
you know kind of you know attacking them
but in
in a loving way i think and you know i
mean it's
you know the country's so you know
there's so much
you know disunity right now that that
that i feel like this book is sort of
like just trying to look at each state
and you know for your show there's a lot
of
there's a lot of interesting things i'd
like to talk to you about go forward
with my book namely
why do you think only certain states
love college basketball
more than college football so i'm
talking about north carolina
kentucky indiana those
are the ones i can think of offhand that
a college basketball and there's no
reason for it
do you have to think about that do you
have a theory at all
well i mean for for for
for kentucky and north carolina i feel
like it's because
they're those appalachian kind of guys
that are kind of tall
and raw boned so i think early on they
were just more into that
and indiana i there's there's no way
they should be into it
except it's the opposite of what they do
all day they work in farms
so they just all day is the opposite of
like a hardwood court
they're outdoors in nature but i guess i
wouldn't explain why
you know most states are football i
would agree especially southern states
no no no no indiana it's just yeah no
there's no doubt about that that's an
interesting
uh you know those are what other states
could we even say that for
where i mean and usually be like oh yeah
well i guess the fact that north
carolina
has also had uh michael jordan that'll
so you'll never basically one of the
greatest athletes in the history of the
world
uh you know doesn't matter before that
yeah no well no no there's definitely
before that it's just like obviously now
these days
uh we've got we've got four states if
you don't mind um
uh that i'd love to that are represented
here in this studio if you want to go
and tell me a little something from the
book or either off the top of your head
about what you
observed or whatever roast you want to
put okay colin quinn here on the rich
eisen show
we'll start with my guy from maine
across the way chris brockman is uh
represents the state of maine do you
have anything from the state of maine
well yeah maine is maine is the new
england of new england
you know what i mean like the way new
england looks at everybody else like
shame on you
you know just keep you know that's how
maine looks at the rest of new england
they're the ones like every section in
the country has one state
that is more more them than they are and
that's what maine is you know
would you agree actually that's more of
new england than new england it's very
fair
and they were very and they were you
know they were very poor because
only four people could afford lobster
until like 1950.
so you know they had lobster nobody
cared it's a problem for the economy
that's a that's a local economy issue
all right uh
next up uh my buddy tj jefferson is from
the great state of pennsylvania what did
you
learn about the keystone state uh colin
oh well i mean
you know pennsylvania is like that's
that's where the entire
country that's like our whole country is
pennsylvania
is based on you know this this thing and
it's you're either a philly
personality you're either like the east
part of pennsylvania
or the cradle of quarterbacks you know
so like
philly is basketball and
pittsburgh is football right and this
and it's it sets up a whole dynamic
where you see
it really represents the entire country
in a way because
that conflict could be can be
embody our entire nation so where do you
put that i mean because i know you've
you you break the book into sections
pennsylvania might fall through the
cracks right here new england
mid-atlantic the south the midwest
southwest
west the pacific coast and then the two
states you call the country's foster
children who is that
hawaii and alaska yeah yum
is the other thing about silly about uh
pennsylvania by the way right is because
you know pittsburgh like the fans are
obsessed with the steelers
like you go when i whenever i've been to
pittsburgh over the years
it's 1975. i would go on stage
little kids and old ladies reading steal
his digest by the way
when you're in town they reach and you
make a you make a joke about like you
know
i don't know like mel blount or like
john dockery and the whole crowd
even the little kids are like hahaha
they literally teach it
like religion they know the steel is
backwards and forwards there's
mike webster jokes there's nowhere else
you could do this kind of stuff
that's right got to know your audience
all right my buddy mike del tufo's
jersey
i think the last two are going to be up
here up your alley new jersey what do
you got for me on that colin
oh well new jersey i mean just the fact
that we have
just the fact that we dump our garbage
that they're basically
we dump our garbage there that that's
such a relationship often
you know i mean that they have the low
self-esteem when we go hey man
can you throw this out for me and we're
like yeah they go yeah okay thanks all
right thank you
that's that's that says it all okay very
good and then the wii is the last one
i'm from staten island new york colin
so uh new york what is your that's the
we in that equation when you say that
right
yeah well but but uh but except staten
island's not the
staten island as you know is its own
city state it always has been
i mean staten island they it's
they don't even have like a town hall
they have like a social club
set up instead of a town hall
oh my gosh so
the social club aspect of it are you
talking about the guy once got shot
outside of spark steakhouse
is that what you're talking about yeah
well yeah
well if he was the only guy that would
be a different story that's right you
know
but in the old days the mob what i say
about new york is in the old days before
you know
if you wanted to in that if you wanted
to put up a high-rise
you had to go to luncheonette and talk
to a guy from the kennedy d's family in
lower manhattan for the cement
and then you know if you wanted building
permits you had to go to a car service
in staten island
those are the guys from the gambinos
plumbers you had to go to a candy store
in brooklyn
you had to go to like five different
stores
to talk to somebody you know air rights
you had to go to a quote
zoning board at a pizza parlor in queens
and now it's just a whole different city
oh my god colin quinn here on the rich
eisen show and interestingly enough your
hbo
max special um he just shot it at a
repurposed drive-in
in brooklyn is that what you did well
yeah they opened to drive in
in green point because of corona i guess
it was like a you know the warehouse and
a bunch of
places there and it was just we get
there and they're like well we'll rent
it to you
to shoot a special and i was like oh
that's great
and we we go there it's got views of the
city
from like a a 50 million dollar movie
so it's this driving special with me and
you know most of my dirtbag comedian
friends
and it was nice if none of us should
dress up for it by the way
and if the backdrop it looks like you
know
you want to hear like george gershwin
playing in the background okay it's so
beautiful
and we spend the whole time insulting
each other and basically performing for
cars
so there's you don't even hear laughs
because they're cars they just
flash their lights and hunt their horns
when they think something's funny no
kids
in the whole special it's called summer
of 2020 a drive-in comedy special who
are the uh
who are the dirtbag comedian friends of
yours that you're referring to um
well you're talking about uh bobby kelly
keith robinson marina franklin rachel
feinstein
rich voice and bonnie mcfarland sam jay
christos stefano dan soder and uh send
me
soda i love soda by the way soda's
probably out of his mind because his
denver nuggets are actually performing
so well in the playoffs right now we
should get
we should get dan on on on the show on
that oh my god yeah he's obs he's
obsessed with his stupid denver team
you're right that's right he's totally
probably going crazy hey colin thanks
for the call man congrats on the book
congrats to the special and then you've
got hubie halloween coming up on uh
netflix in just a couple of weeks so you
got that going on
yeah that's gonna be great october 7th
thank you you take care colin you got it
that's uh that i am
i am colin quinn on both twitter and
instagram right here on the show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here